[Musique]
il ya quelques semaines j'ai demandé des
jeunes béninois dans les rues de cotonou
qui était ce qui les inspire est et
n'ont pas pu me répondre
et pourtant qui sont ceux qui vivent
dans les abris si lever la main ok parce
que j'avais une amie égyptienne dont les
amis lui demandait si les africains
vivaient dans les arbres et le soir des
faits une publication j'ai dit ok moi je
dors dans la branche numéro b
aujourd'hui et toi ok l'afrique au fait
c'est le continent ou via les clichés
les plus tenaces la corruption la
famille la drogue la guerre
l'instabilité les politiciens et vous
savez nous avons grandi dans cet
environnement nous a dit que nous les
africains nous étions si nous les
africains nous étions ça c'est comme si
il y avait un méritage de la
colonisation
un héritage des années des siècles je
dirais dspe la rage et ça allait servir
ici qu'aux logique
nous avons grandi dans un environnement
où le fatalisme nous empêche de réussir
non les africains chaque fois que vous
entendez quelqu'un dire nous les
africains non les noirs ne s'échouent
mouvement pour dire un truc négatif et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya le mieux dedans
socrates non c'est pas socrate aristote
aristote a dit que nous apprenons les
vertus pratique de ce qui nous entoure
et de nombreuses études scientifiques
ont confirmé cela ce que nous sommes
c'est ce que nous voyons c'est ce que
nous lisons et c'est surtout ce que nous
côtoyons vous savez les vertus comme
être honnête les vertus comme ne pas
voler les vertus comme être bon
travailleur ce n'est pas parce qu'on
nous a dit qu'il fallait les avoirs que
nous les avons nous les avons tout
simplement parce que nous avons vu des
gens le faire et aussi parce que vous a
tapé un peu mais bon j'ai envie de vous
parler d'inspiration lorsque la régie
m'a demandé de quoi je voulais pas j'ai
dit que j'allais vous avez donné
africains mais en fait je veux pas les
d'inspiration africaine
vous connaissez le premier homme en fait
le premier africain à avoir fait le tour
du monde
non qu'ils le conte est levé la main il
s'appelle admis lola à douze jurés à des
milanais à douze journées a fait le tour
du monde en solo c'était en 2016
lorsqu'on lui a demandé pourquoi il a
fait cela c'est le message qu'ils
voulaient envoyer il a dit l'afrique a
besoin de modèles je rencontre des
jeunes enfants de jeunes africains qui
me disent qu'il est impossible d'être
pilote parce qu'ils sont noirs et je
veux leur montrer que s'il faut je veux
leur montrer que je suis la preuve
qu'ils peuvent le faire je vais vous
parler de toutes ces personnes dont nous
avons besoin de jeunes africains des
africains comme vous comme moi qui
montrent que c'est possible qu'ils ne
croient pas en l'impossible des jeunes
africains des game centers
je ne voulais pas le pitch en anglais
parce que franchement si vous m'écoutez
parler en anglais
vous allez rire
nous avons besoin de jeunes qui nous
montre qu'on peut être noir et faire de
grandes choses
chaque fois qu'on parle d'un modèle de
réussite si c'est pas un blanc c'est
sûrement en afrique et américains c'est
vrai ils sont noirs comme nous mais est
ce qu'ils ont vécu dans le même
environnement que nous est ce qu'ils ont
vécu comme nous cette difficulté dont
stevie a parlé est ce qu'ils ont vécu la
galère le plus plus de midi très violent
moi j'ai vu ça je bois sont encore est
ce qu'il en veut plus attendre nous nous
avons besoin des africains qui sont nés
en afrique qui ont vécu dans notre
environnement et qui pourtant ont réussi
lorsque angélique kidjo a gagné son
troisième grammy awards fric s'il vous
plaît elle a dédié cela à la jeunesse
africaine aux jeunes
six artistes musiciens africains mais
vous savez c'était complètement inutile
parce que angeli kidjo de ouidah à new
yok angélique kidjo du bénin à ce sommet
la enduit quito qui ont réussi à gagner
trois grammy awards c'est un signal fort
pour tous les jeunes africains pour tous
les jeunes musiciens qui ont envie de
devenir quelque chose c'est de ça que
nous avons besoin de ces personnes là on
les appelle des rôles modernes
l'afrique a besoin de modèles lorsque
j'étais plus jeune j'avais une obsession
je voulais à tout prix trouver quelqu'un
à qui ressemblait je disais mais non je
veux pas être marie elise gbèdo et tout
elle porte une perruque et moi j'ai des
cheveux
que lui dites pas ça s'il vous plaît et
quand on m'a dit je ressemble à mon père
je dis non je veux pas ressembler à mon
père vous paie n'a pas de cheveux aussi
et pendant des années j'ai cherché
quelqu'un qui ressemblait et depuis deux
ans je passe mon temps à interviewer les
jeunes africains qui ont de ces
histoires qui ont de l'inspiration à
donner et je me suis rendu compte que
tous avaient quelque chose à offrir au
monde
ils ont une histoire à raconter ils ont
un talon a montré et ils ont pris le
patient à bras le corps et l'ont fait et
j'ai moi vous demandez à chacun d'entre
vous quel que soit ce que vous aimez
faire quel que soit ce qui nous est
votre cesse votre race je m'en fous mais
qui que vous soyez fait en sorte d'être
une inspiration pour les autres je me
rue mais la magie de l'inspiration en
nevers magnifique de marianne williamson
elle a dit tout simplement
chaque fois que vous autoriser à faire
briller votre moi chaque fois que vous
autorisez être merveilleux vous donner
la permission à d'autres d'être pareil
ainsi vous demandez qui suis-je poitou
priant talentueux radieux et merveilleux
vous avez tort de vous demander ça
demandez vous plutôt qui êtes vous pour
le ppt être une inspiration pour
l'afrique inspiré l'afrique inspiré le
monde s'il vous plaît changez le monde
du stade partir de votre passion je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]